and welcome to wo CheY cafe I'm mr. John
Farley I'm here with singer-songwriter
Adele's and time enough to visit us and
sing some songs from her new album and
your new album is called 21 yeah your
last album was called 19 yeah you're 22
years old now so what do you know now
that you didn't know when you released
her first up when you're 19 I'm mr.
Afton I'm just had a few more life
experiences obviously I'm older so I've
had you know more years on earth I just
look at things a very different light to
how I used to I was very I was very much
a teenager when I wrote my first album
was very stubborn everything I knew I
thought was all I needed to know and
everything I liked I thought I'd never
like anything else and I'm a patient and
more interested and forgiving less
expectant lots of different things I had
the best relationship ever
and the worst breakup ever that's all on
the album sold on the record yeah I'm
there and the new record at the old
record and mid-nineteen you a lot from
soul music the new record has some other
kinds of influences can you tell me
about those yeah we got into country and
bluegrass and rockabilly and gospel
there's still lots of so on it and so
bits of like pop and folk as well but I
was here touring for so long I just it
was kind of became my hobby to discover
Americana music I haven't made a country
record but certainly the kind of
delivery and the immediate kind of oh
yeah I know what you're talking about
you know I've tried to incorporate that
into this record I really don't want to
try and ever be one of those artists
that wants to be really cool and trendy
and nine minutes into like experimental
instrumental he's still wondering what
the top songs about you know what I like
about countryside in the first 10
seconds you know exactly what the songs
about well I'm wondering because you're
such a young artist what drives you did
all the sort of vintage music forms like
the blues and you know all kinds of
country even what drives you to that
totally solid it's like it's not far
away at all and they convinced me I'm
when I listened to them kind of artists
and not all of them but lots of them I
immediately convinced they're singing
about
even though is recorded 40 years before
I was born and I thank God that filled
that bond with modern music I don't I
mean there's lots of songs I have no
idea who sings in these days because
they're just a single you know so I love
the history and you know I buy into
everything that those artists represent
from back then I mean then there's just
something quite like fascinating by
listening to music that was recorded and
written and you know before you were
born as well a couple years ago you won
the Grammy for Best New Artist did you
find it to be a burden or blessing a
mixture both what how did it have the
award impact your career I think a lot
more people were interested after Beth
oh and when people were aware with me
especially here and Esther the Grammys
travels worldwide I mean it's like you
know like every country kind of has
their own Awards Grammys like in
Hollands they're like well you know if
whoever wears a bit like war Grammy
whereas people aren't like well we've
got this award and you can win it in
somewhere else you know just in that one
place so definitely kind of kind of
everyone was very interested but it was
ways because it was right at the end of
of my campaign you know so it wasn't it
wasn't yeah I didn't I didn't notice but
now I know it's clever I go that's my
introduction which is quite amazing you
know there's still a bit like I feel
like I'm in a secret member's Club I get
thrown out early in your career social
media really helped spread the word on
you and your work
I don't thinking more about that and is
it something that you still are sort of
into and does it still helps them get
your music out there yeah well I was my
friend's head out for me my friend set
my music MySpace in 2004 I think it was
I was 14 or 15 and then I wasn't really
interested in it and my suppose hadn't
taken off in England yet and as part of
my course to learn how to use like
recording equipment so I'd record these
demos and whatever and I'd give my demos
to my friend Linden because I didn't I
don't listen to my music
I gave him them and then he started
putting them on there and he kept saying
to me over the period for to 2004 to
2006 someone's emailed you from like
Sony or something and I'd be like oh
really
oh yeah probably just like an internet
perv or something you know like if
you've seen those go and then it was
alright I care I won't answer and then
the day I finished college he gave me
the password
here's what I think you should go on it
now
I don't think they are internet pervs I
think they're serious and I went on and
had all these emails and then three days
later I was in the office three days
after finishing college I was 18 is not
like university college I was in the
offices of Excel who I ended up signing
me didn't sign me three days later best
the first time I met them and I don't
really I just get really paranoid about
people not hacking into stuff so I don't
have a Facebook really anything like
that I don't go on it cuz I get scared
about people nicking information not
about me just in general it just scares
me like you know like big brother who
scares me in general and one of the you
new songs is in the movie I am Number
Four excited about that yeah yeah now I
am ya know I am five and what song is it
and how was it used rolling it I don't
know if I'm asking with too much weight
was rolling in the day that time um when
it's a scene where one of the other
numbers like you realized that she's
there because he thinks everyone else is
dead we have a numbers and she's there
and she's um yes she's fierce playing
it's a movie about a group of aliens
it's on earth being hunted by other
aliens yeah yeah oh great well I
appreciate you come to the WUSA cafe
Adelle thanks a lot thank you
you